if someone says to me i am content
i am happy i have everything i have you
know a mansion i'm a millionaire this
this this this and you know tries to say
what you're saying is wrong
i'll say to them we'll see we'll see
because in their darkest moments
they know that all of this is nonsense
all of this is nonsense and uh
i think muslims should look into you
know
psychology and you know what people feel
at death you know or near to death or
and the sort of things that
they discuss when people aren't
palliative care you know end of life
so regrets they have and these types of
things i watch videos
of people who are you know dying
and they have you know all sorts of
diseases and you you get these videos on
youtube where people are just
in their last stages some people are
young some people are old it keeps me
grounded it reminds me because there is
nothing which is more powerful
i believe than the constant reminder of
death i try and remind myself of death
as much as possible why
because i want to be intelligent because
the most intelligent people according to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
are the people who remember death and
are prepared
for death you're not intelligent
if you can do all these great things
yet the hereafter which is going to go
on forever you haven't prepared anything
for it
and you put all of your eggs in this
world
which the prophet peace be upon him
described as a
dead goat you know
um sometimes when you're on social media
you know and you get these things you
know
you go on to instagram you go into
facebook whatever you start scrolling
yeah
you get people who are going on holidays
or you get you know these amazing
sceneries or some guys like
i made a thousand dollars in five
minutes and this and that you get all
these materialism things and as you're
scrolling scrolling scrolling
you know the jarlich world view the
materialistic world view is telling you
you know come to this come to this come
to this fit now come to this uh
thing every single one of them whether
it's a pretty woman
whether it's money whether it's status
whether it's image
you should imagine it's a dead goal
someone's holding up a dead
diseased goat which is rotting and
saying to you
want to have a buy of this want to have
a buy of this like honestly you should
imagine
everybody that's trying to sell you this
materialistic world view they're trying
to sell you a dead
goat right don't go for the goat
don't go for the goat remember the
greatest of all time
the greatest man of all time is the
prophet peace be upon him and he is the
one who taught us
don't go for that dead goat understand
that this world is absolutely
meaningless and the true life
is the life that begins once we pass
[Music]
away
[Music]
[Music]
so my eyes character is a thing about a
video game think about a movie
you think about a book you have
different characters
the character is uh the expressions the
actions
the personality the traits of this
individual
good character would imply obviously
that this person leads
towards good bad would imply that they
lean towards bad but
having character in general uh implies
authenticity or at least
i would say good character implies
authenticity
so if you don't mind me asking because
um i forgive me on my ignorance here but
this is the first time that i meet you
and um i i don't usually watch any
videos
um i usually just watch like what
brother you know fayette or romney or
anyone else sends me
but have you been a muslim your entire
life yeah
bro so would you say that you had a
uh a moment where it all clicked for you
or do you
do you think this this has been
something that's like since the
beginning
you've always just kind of been there
slowly growing more and more
um very good question
i would say i found islam
at university right so i went to city
university in london
um when i came to university
i used to pray the friday prayer other
than that
i didn't know i didn't know what either
i didn't know islamic history
i didn't know many other things just the
basic stuff that the average
person just learns as a child you know
it was the truth though
yes however
i would say
i would say that you're just it's like a
cultural thing
right so you're muslim you
you know the teachings and you're like
okay this makes sense that makes sense
but i think you know
at university for me it was like
this is the absolute truth this isn't
just
oh it's not just a and
i remember you know attending the friday
uh
khutbahs and stuff and you know one
particular hotbar really
hit me and then other and then i started
you know i was always into
you know looking into evidences and this
type of stuff so i think university is a
time where
you know you can either go into the
direction of you know partying drinking
womanizing and this type of thing or you
can go down the direction of
life is so short you know start asking
yourselves
these existential questions my father
passed away when i was at university
my father was very close to me and he
was in his
40s he wasn't even that old and that
really hit me
so you know you start thinking about
morality as immortality and
you know existentialism and you know all
of these deep topics and
it's just something which i
i believe that that was for me an
intellectual conversion when i looked
into islam and its evidences and
and then studied akita and you know
these it wasn't just okay i'm muslim
my parents are muslim and you know this
type of thing um
i always had this type of
islamic identity but
having islamic identity is it could be
just linked to you being pakistani
right you know um it could be just you
being linked to a particular race or
whatever
and sometimes these things are
convoluted together but you really have
to study islam and say to yourself
this is something that i want to make my
life
and another thing for me which was very
clear especially the more i started to
practice and stuff
there is no happiness there is
no happiness in anything except
submission to the creator like someone
says oh they're partying and drinking
and doing drugs and womanizing and their
billionaire and this and this and this
and this
would i like to trade my life
for one year with somebody who has no
iman
allahu akbar never i will never do that
there is nothing
there is nothing that will make you more
content
more at peace more happier than the
religion of al-islam
nothing you know why is it
why is it that you get you know and i i
think young people
need to think about this why is it that
people go on these streaks of
you know going off for a career and
becoming popular and this and this and
this
and the end of their career some people
commit suicide people go into depression
some people drink themselves to death
you know there's a famous musician
avensia or this guy
avicii avicii avicii right
look at the guy was drinking then he cut
himself and he died
he's drinking a wine bottle and he
smashed it and he
cut his wrists and died like that and
you know one of the things his family
said about him is that
you know the meaning of life and these
types of things were disturbing him and
he wanted to know why he existed and
you know this is a guy and just just
take this guy as an example
mega famous super popular
right rich you know all these women
around him and you know
everything he wants everything that the
materialistic worldview tells you
here is this thing that you should
strive for
avicii had was he happy
no nothing will make you happier than
the relationship you have with allah why
because allah made you for that allah
made you for his love allah made you so
that
you have hope and trust and fear and
love
purely for him and anything anything
that disrupts that
will make you miserable if someone says
to me
i am content i am happy i have
everything i have you know
a mansion i'm a millionaire this this
this this and
you know tries to say what you're saying
is wrong
i'll say to them we'll see we'll see
because in their darkest moments
they know that all of this is
nonsense all of this is nonsense
and uh i think muslims should look into
you know psychology and you know
what people feel at death you know or
near to death
or and the sort of things that they
discuss
when people are palliative care you know
end of life so regrets they have and
these types of things
i watch videos of people who are
you know dying and they have you know
all sorts of diseases and you get these
videos on youtube where people are just
in their last stages some people are
young some people are old it keeps me
grounded it reminds me because there is
nothing which is more powerful
i believe than the constant reminder of
death i
try and remind myself of death as much
as possible why
because i want to be intelligent because
the most intelligent people according to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
are the people who remember death and
are prepared
for death you're not intelligent
if you can do all these great things
yet the hereafter which is going to go
on forever you haven't prepared anything
for it
and you put all of your eggs in this
world
which the prophet peace be upon him
described as a
dead goat you know
um sometimes when you're on social media
you know and you get these things you
know
you go on to instagram you go into
facebook whatever you start scrolling
yeah
you get people who are going on holidays
or you get you know these amazing
sceneries or some guys like
i made a thousand dollars in five
minutes and this and that you get all
these materialism things and as you're
scrolling scrolling scrolling
you know the jarlich world view the
materialistic world view is telling you
you know come to this come to this come
to this fit now come to this
uh thing every single one of them
whether it's a pretty woman whether it's
money whether it's status
whether it's image you should imagine
it's a dead goal
someone's holding up a dead diseased
goat which is
rotting and saying to you want to have a
buy of this
want to have a buy of this like honestly
you should imagine
everybody that's trying to sell you this
materialistic world view they're trying
to sell you a dead
goat right don't go for the goat
don't go for the goat remember the
greatest of all time
the greatest man of all time is the
prophet peace be upon him and he is the
one who taught us
don't go for that dead goat understand
that this world is absolutely
meaningless and the true life
is the life that begins once we pass
away
i can i can directly attest
to what you've said because i've i've
lived on the other side of the fence
i had all this stuff man i had i was
talking to multiple women i lived on my
own i had a motorcycle i had my car
bro i had unlimited
access to any drug that i wanted
and it all it gave me was this
temporary feeling of happiness it wasn't
even happiness it was not
i can't say it was bro i've been in
relationships where
again i'm not saying any of this to
boast but it's like i had unlimited
access to anything i wanted a very
hedonistic
lifestyle very hedonistic pursuit and
um it's not the same
it's not the same when when you submit
to the creator
the peace that we experience the
happiness that we experience
in the creator is unlike anything that
this world has to offer
and i think uh newman ali khan had said
it in one of his uh
buzz where he's like if you're searching
for happiness
in the dunya where you're searching in
the wrong place because like
nothing here is going to give you this
happiness this is temporary the dunya is
temporary so how's anything
here going to give you permanent
happiness permanent peace
and man like i don't know i don't know
if the people around me have uh
noticed this but you know wallahi
the other day i was just reflecting i
was like man lookie
look at myself look at my character look
at who i've become look at the way that
i carry myself look at the way that i
treat
others look at look at my life now like
if this is not a direct
attestment or a test of testimony
of me becoming muslim and the changes
that that has had on my life
then i don't know what is because man i
used to spend time with my family and i
was never fully present
i was never there i wasn't really happy
and if i was it was like
it was a conditional happiness i was
happy because
things were going good with my girl i
was happy because i had money i was
happy
because you know i was working now and i
was diesel when i was
you know i had my best physique or
something like that but now it's like
man i'm just i'm just happy to be on
a mustache on the straight path brother
it's like i'm i'm here with my family
and like
i like i said i don't know if they
noticed this but i noticed in myself i
was like alhamdulillah bro
alhamdulillah like bro again just like
you said
i wouldn't trade i wouldn't trade my
life
for that of uh the highest ranking
kuffar in this world
is that we human beings go through a
burnout
when we are following our desires now i
was doing
some research a few years ago and i came
across a really interesting study to do
with monkeys
right so we all know of the chemical
dopamine right
sorry the neurotransmitter dopamine
and this is something which is the if
you like the pleasure hormone and it's
what people chase
you know you see something uh which you
desire and
that's what it is you know it's it's you
okay you're super hungry you look at a
burger
that's released or or an image or
whatever it is
what's interesting is in this story with
monkey in this study with monkeys what
they did is they measured
the dopamine uh pleasure uh the level of
dopamine that was released when um
when when the monkey saw something they
liked so
what it did in the study is that
it had this way of measuring when the
monkey had that pleasure
that dopamine release and what they did
is a light came on
when the monkey was in this uh
particular cell a light came on the
monkey went and
pushed a button and food came out and
the monkey
so then what scientists noticed is every
single time the light flashed because
the light was off
when the light flashed the monkey went
and pressed and it got the food
what it realized is the monkey its
highest pleasure
was when it saw the red light
and as it went to press the button and
the food came out the pleasure is going
down and his eating is
still getting pleasure but the highest
pleasure is when it saw the
red light or whatever the thing is
and what they did is every single time
the monkey
randomly is waiting there the light
comes on it presses it it gets food
what they did is they added they added
randomness to it
so before every single time the monkey
pressed the button and got food
now what they did is they made it random
sometimes the monkey got food when they
pressed the button
sometimes you didn't get food so now
there's uncertainty before the
uncertainty
you go there press say you get food
whenever the lights on
now this uncertainty
you would expect the pleasure to go down
the dopamine release to go down
right it was actually the opposite it
went way higher
it went way higher and this
is interesting because now that it's
uncertain
that whether the monkey will get that
food or not the pleasure goes higher but
the pleasure still is the highest
when it first sees it and when you
correlate this study with
people who are addicts to heroin
addicts to pornography addicts to
alcohol addicts to any of these things
and different brain scans with these
people
the more they go into that desire
the less dopamine is released over time
they've done brain scans to show
this right that the brain they'll they
show their brain there they'll show a
red spot
where the high pleasure of the dopamine
is then a yellow spot
which is less and less and somebody
that's
an addict over time the red disappears
the red's the highest pleasure and all
you get is dots of yellow
so over time pleasure goes down and down
and down and down the more someone
gambles and fornicates and does whatever
so interestingly enough people go
through a hedonistic
burnout over time the pleasure
is the highest when you're not addicted
but when you get addicted and you follow
into that desire
it goes down and down and down and down
and that's why
you know people no longer get pleasure
from just
you know having a girlfriend you know
the girlfriend will have to flipping
uh chain them to a wall and they're
gonna have to be whipped or something
somebody else is not happy with weed
they're gonna have to stick in heroin
they have to increase every single time
he's not just going to gamble
um money you know you you get people who
gamble their wives you know if
i lose then this this guy can sleep with
his wife whatever other people gamble
their houses
you have to do something extreme but you
still won't get that dopamine release
that you had before islam comes in and
says
stop being a chemical head yeah
stop being a addict to dopamine you have
a
greater goal and guess what
dopamine is released when you have that
hoshu in salah
dopamine is released when you have that
connection with the quran
dopamine is released when we're here
we're talking about allah and it's
making us feel
better and this type of dopamine release
it gets better better and better and you
don't burn out
right so the fact is the happy life
the true happy life is the life with
islam
it's not the life where you're just a
chemical head
chasing these shattered dreams which
lead eventually to depression
look at all these addicts why are they
depressed they're depressed because
they've released their dopamine so much
that that the actual uh cognitive
architecture of the brain the actual
machinery that releases the dopamine
because it's constantly being used it
gets
burnt out its ability to produce
dopamine burns out if you're going to
use
this camera that we're using right now
24 7 the camera is going to break down
it's going to start glittering jittering
it's going to start having issues with
anything
they have no break because they're
constantly releasing dopamine
because the brain gets no break because
there's no restrictions
because there's no uncertainty in human
beings love uncertainty
this is why there's depression so what
you're saying brother
is not just something which we are just
talking about even
science tells us giving in to your
desires
is the worst way of actually being happy
it's called uh i think desensitization
i know this brother because yeah
unfortunately in my jahilia
i was uh very very addicted to
pornography man and the the worst thing
is like you do it so much
that you start watching worse and worse
things and
alhamdulillah i never got into like
really terrible things but
listen i've i've had clients whose names
all keep
confidential but they got so
deep into it that they started watching
homosexual
pornography and then they start
questioning whether they are gay or if
they're straight
a lot of work bro and if you imagine
the same thing happening in porn the
same thing happening in gambling the
same thing happening
in terms of your following of wealth
right
every single time you have to do
something more extreme
every single time for example there's
somebody who wants to be
i want to be rich i want to be a rich
they they
they don't manage to do it in in the
legitimate way they'll start finding
illegitimate ways or some people this
happens they pretend to be rich
right other people you know they're
constantly trying to make themselves
look better and better so then they go
under the knife and get plastic surgery
more and more and more and what starts
to happen
people refuse to accept the reality the
reality is
that you don't have those things that
you had when you're younger so
as you're getting older your body's
getting weaker you're starting to get
wrinkles you're starting to look old
you're starting to get gray hair
and if you're muslim whatever comes your
way
you know someone throws a kitchen sink
at you
someone does this someone does that you
know
every single thing that's happening to
you this life is a test
right so the believer when when
everything's coming at them
so when they're healthy they're grateful
when they're not healthy
they're patient the believer is in
success at every single moment
but the person who is hedonistic who is
constantly just looking for pleasure
pleasure pleasure what starts to happen
is that the smallest thing happens and
they can't handle it no more
you know there's a friend i met a few um
a few years ago and he said
uh something very interesting to me he
was
at that time that i met him he had a
long beard and he was giving dawah
and you know he's he's just somebody
that you thought was always practicing
islam
but he told me that actually he was not
practicing
islam before he was totally jahil he
said
you know i used to have all these hair
styles and this and that and as he
started getting older he started getting
bolder
right he said that really made him like
you know worried oh my god i'm losing my
hair and this and this like all these
small things
later on when he started practicing
losing hair
gray hair or health problems it was all
like
yellow no problem bismillah what's the
issue do you have money good you don't
have money no problem
you know you you're kind of like
indifferent to the world
and that's why you know these types of
people and you know this brother because
you are non-muslim
these types of people like you said
their happiness is
so contingent as soon as they find out
that oh you know i'm with this girl
and this and this and this but actually
there's another girl and she's prettier
than this and this one's getting old and
this and that
they're constantly not happy you know
they're never happy with their car
never happy with their house never happy
with their spouse they're never
in a state of happiness and even even it
comes to a point where
people only select their friends because
well they got money or they got
something to offer
and there is no true friendship there is
no true empathy
right i mean look at look at us here i
don't know you guys
until we went on to this live stream you
don't know me we're connected by iman
i don't want money from you i don't want
status for me i don't want anything from
you don't want anything from me
we're both here because we love islam
and we want to share islam
this is what islam provides bring it on
what does atheism provide
like honestly you know when atheists say
oh atheism is right i'm like okay
bring it on tell me what does atheism
provide
okay if i become an atheist now what do
i do with my life
go ahead what do i do what's the meaning
of life
do whatever you want you're gonna make
enough to your god and not feel guilty
that's all you get
yeah what is it
just follow you enough follow your
desire okay fine and what
after that honestly
i just cannot believe there are people
in this world
who never ever question where did i come
from why am i here where am i going
how can you live your entire life and
not think about these things
well it just it goes to show how allah
says in the quran
that uh he guides who he was like
there's some people who are
it's as if they were deaf blind and dumb
like nothing you say nothing they see
nothing that happens
it's not gonna do anything for them you
could show them the truth right there in
their face
and they're just going to be like ah
that's that's not it that's not it
man the proof is in the pudding right
and the proof is you know um
if someone wants to really
know islam is the truth i would honestly
not give them an argument for god's
existence or an argument for the quran
being true although i can
i'll say to them if you really want to
know islam is true
then call upon the creator
call upon you know in english we say god
in persian we say
whatever you know got in german whatever
you believe in one supreme being
just call upon that being and say can i
have guidance
even once sincerely god will
show you what the truth is you know some
people say
oh i read the quran didn't make any
sense oh i don't believe in religion
i say to them you're just simply
arrogant and you're not sincere no i am
i am sincere
oh okay um
i know and i know people that this has
happened to and has definitely happened
to me
you call upon god god will answer you if
someone says to me
no i ask for guidance and are sincere
and i never got guidance
in fact i got guided to believing in i
don't know a llama is god or
atheism i would say you're a liar and
they'll say prove me wrong i'll say no i
don't prove you wrong on the day of
judgement we'll see but you're a liar
you're a flipping liar anybody who says
they made a sincere
supplication to god for guidance and
they were not guided
and you know they try and say that you
know
i'm sincere and i never got guidance
either they've given up they said it
once or
they didn't do it properly or whatever
or they're just totally lying
the fact is if you want an iphone
13 which is going to come out this year
what do you find
you find people who are willing to in
central london in the cold
which is it's going to come out like
october it's going to be freezing here
in london right
they're going to actually get a blanket
get sleeping bags all night they're
gonna stand out for a phone
for a phone they're gonna go stand out
and struggle
to be the first ones to buy it but for
faith
for iman you're not willing to put in
the same
struggle and the same energy oh god give
me a sign oh there's no sign oh i don't
believe in god
come on we put in so much effort in our
degrees
in our marriages uh you know to to pick
up
wealth and you know pick up phones put
in some
effort for the sake of your eternal
eternity
and you putting in that effort it's
impossible that god will not respond to
you
god will respond allah says in the quran
call upon me i will respond to you
oh and sometimes they receive guidance
or they receive a sign and they either
say that it's them
or this is my doing or two they
they claim that it's coincidence or
three they
they try to give some other uh
explanation for it they don't say this
guys
you know yeah yeah the universe bro okay
so here's the story y'all when i was uh
ajah
i was getting into the new age stuff you
know you heard about this stuff
right yeah yeah oh man so when i was
getting into it i was thinking about the
law of attraction and i was like 2015
and i was
like hmm the love attraction like how
nice would it be for me to manifest
a reality and have all the money that i
could ever want
and uh never have to worry about bills
have all the food i want
i'll get the car that i want get the
house that i want go traveling
see where my mind was at here right very
materialistic very
dunya oriented and they have this uh
this test that you do and what you do is
you basically
ask the universe right you ask the
universe
right universe you ask the universe
to uh send you a sign
and make it clear to you that that's a
sign there's no question there's no
doubting just make it clear to you that
that's a sign listen
if i tell any muslim this the first
thing you think about it's the harder
you think about it's istahara pray right
so
i had this thing i did this and wallahi
i had two signs that were unquestionable
like there was no me questioning it but
then i was like oh
it's the universe and then you know what
end you know what
ended up happening after that completely
forgot
and then i started thinking ah well that
was uh just a coincidence it wasn't real
or anything like that and like bro how
many people are going through the same
thing
when it's like bro that was god right
there that was
god just showing you just a snippet
and you know what's interesting is
people who worship idols
it's not the case that they call upon
the id like they're just worshiping
these idols and nothing happens
it's allah who answers their duas but
they subscribe it to the
idols and you know what's interesting is
that
a person can interpret something in a
particular way
they can be like okay this means this
but deep down a lot of people
know right and wrong so what you said
reminded me
of a guy i met a few years ago it's
actually me and hamza sots
this guy contacted us he was a doctor
in central london and you know he was a
militant atheist
and he was dying from this disease and
he prayed to god he said god if you cure
me
i'll be thankful and i'll find the truth
then he was miraculously cured
right in a way that surprised the
doctors even though he's a doctor
himself you realize wow this is amazing
once he came out he actually went back
on what he said to god
he said oh the human body fixes itself
you know maybe this happened maybe that
happened
he reversed it then he said no
no no no i know what that was that was
god right
then he looked into it and he started
looking into religion alhamdulillah in
the end he looked into islam and became
muslim
the fact is everybody knows there is
something beyond this wealth
if they deep down think about it now
sadly they do shirk by calling upon the
universe or calling upon the idols or or
these types of things
but ultimately everything that happens
is from allah
everything that happens is from allah
and you know
i find it very hard to believe that
there
is truly atheists out there that deep
down they actually believe
the physical world is all that there is
anybody who is a critical thinker who
thinks deeply about this
it doesn't take long before you think to
yourself
surely there has to be something beyond
this world who made this world
everybody in their own personal lives
they will see signs you know how many if
you go out on the street and
this is something that anybody can go
and test
go and speak to people about true dreams
you'll have non-muslims who'll say i saw
this thing in a dream and then it came
true
or this particular thing happened or i
made this prayer to god and it came true
everybody that actually thinks deeply
about these things
we'll come to recognize sooner or later
naturalism the idea that the world in
nature is all that there is
there's absolute garbage you know you
really have to work
hard to convince yourself that these
things are
you know not there they are there they
are calling out to you you know when you
see a tree or you see a star or
the other day i was in my garden uh and
i was praying and i like praying out in
the open
rather than praying inside the house and
i just prayed and i looked up at the sky
and i felt this rush of iman i don't
know if you guys
had that when you look over the sky and
you can't describe it and you're like
you know people
are trying to tell you oh i don't
believe in god because of the antropic
principle
you're like shut up
you have no idea what you're talking
about you have no idea what you're
missing out on oh
i was uh i was praying at the beach the
other day
and subhanallah like as i was finishing
the um and i
you know i said assalamu alaikum both
sides
finished i opened my eyes and i was just
looking off to the horizon
and just the way the clouds were formed
the breeze that was hitting me
the waves that were just rushing over on
the shore
that's what i'm saying man and the last
thing i was going to say too
is isn't that isn't that better i mean
brother i don't want to go into your
jahili and stuff
isn't that better than the best woman
you've been with the best drug you've
ever taken
or money isn't that better that all of
those things combined together
yeah 100 mother when i had when i had
all this
and like bro i listen i'm gonna be
honest with you
i'll be honest on camera two i do not
mind allah knows best
i've been abstinent for three years
alhamdulillah i haven't even been muslim
for three years but i've been abstinent
for three years so allah was already at
work in my life before i even realized
it
all right me i was engaged at the time
and me and this this woman we split we
parted ways
and i thought to myself you know i'm
going through a lot of pain
i should probably deal with this i
should probably deal with this and
throughout those uh i'd say two two and
a half years before i became muslim
because
it's it's almost a year now that i've
been muslim i would have moments where
i'd be like i'm good i'm ready for women
again like let's go and then we'll start
talking a whole bunch of women and then
god will place this
this barrier in between that and it's
like
i would always be upset because i wanted
to be with them you know obviously my
sexual desires
you know they were rushing over me but
it's like bro
if i can think back all the times that i
was
with a woman all the times that i had a
relationship all the time that i was
doing all this
and we know like how strong those
emotions are
when you are with the opposite gender
the opposite individual and and you guys
have something you guys have a bond and
you guys are
engaging in these uh sexual relations
like
well none of that compares to that
single moment right there on the beach
after so long just looking at everything
you know what i mean you know the kuffar
in the quran they say to the muslims
their religion has deluded them
you know you know in other way in other
words you know
they they look at us and they're like
these guys are not us
no no what i mean is that
they find it hard
to believe that with all of these vices
you get young people who are like no
thanks
you know you get young sisters right you
know 18
19 all the they see people around them
who have boyfriends who have this who
have that who are taking off
uh you know on holidays and they're on
instagram with pictures
showing their hair and their body and
stuff and then you get these sisters who
are like
no thanks you know you get brothers who
are like you know there's weed available
women available drugs available porn
available
you know status this that they're like
no thanks
because these people are strangers right
and they're strangers because they're
hooked on something else they
they're hooked upon this spirituality
and it feels a lot better than
anything the world has to offer so from
an outsider's perspective
islam should have been dead a long time
ago
like islam is telling you you know okay
what's the man's strongest desire
strongest desire for status power
woman prestige wealth
image all these things islam says no you
can't have that and the man says okay
same thing with the woman right you get
all of these things
right which are materialistically
available and attractive and you know
the opposite gender everything
from a non like just think of it from
from the outsiders point of view they
would say these people
are mad all of these things are
available
but they're putting their head on the
floor they're gaining knowledge
they're giving power they're focusing on
other stuff
it makes no sense
but we know that what they're doing is
nonsense
because this is real what they have
is fake
[Music]
if only they knew if only they
if only they knew and how can they know
how can they know unless we tell them
you know when i'm speaking to people and
i try and do a heart to heart
i just try and say to them you know rock
bottom
this is something that's going to give
you
peace and happiness and tranquility
nothing else will nothing will what are
people looking for
what are they really happiness peace and
happiness that's it
that's it look people are not
complicated right people are simple
professors or peasants they want
happiness
islam is there to give you happiness but
here's the beautiful thing about islam
you go to the gym you go through pain
right and all of us have been especially
after the lockdown
i'm sure all of us went through this
during the lockdown you can't go to the
gym but then you go to the gym
and you go through pain you go through
struggle you have to have a particular
structure
you come out of the gym after the
session you had when six months you were
locked
away and you get that rush
you get that release of you know
dopamine and serotonin and all of those
happy chemicals and you walk out of the
gym and you got this breeze and you get
this happiness and then you have your
meal and
you know you feel great that feeling
it didn't come by a drug it didn't come
by
swiping uh you know a credit card it
came by hard work
going to the gym pumping sweating
then you get the rush you get the
happiness after the regime after the
structure after the pain
is painful when that lactic acid is
building in your triceps
but the pain then led to that great
pleasure islam is the same thing
you're sleeping you're completely out of
it
you know you're you know flying through
some
spaceship or whatever and then your fajr
alarm goes off
you had three hours of sleep and you're
like okay
and then you get up you go cold water
you do that then you get
the rush but you have to go through the
pain of waking up you have to go through
the pain
of actually this sometimes happens that
you know it's the winter and it's only
cold water and all of this
you have to go through that lack of
sleep and
discomfort but then you get the pleasure
the problem with
people today and especially the new
generation which everything is instant
gratification
they want the pleasure without the pain
they want the spirituality without the
struggle but these things go hand in
hand
like you know the way i sometimes think
of it in terms of myself
i sometimes imagine or think
that i need to declare war or whip my
own soul
like that's what you got to do you got
to be like
oh i don't feel like doing this i don't
feel like doing that or i feel like
doing this
and you literally have to be like shut
up and fix yourself
you know you have to have that strength
we're not animals
you know an animal sees the opposite
gender right
and just goes and shags right or goes
and eats
the animal wants to defecate it
defecates the animal just does what it
feels like
the human being the muslim the the
men is there for self-restraint
i am not gonna do what i feel like i'm
gonna do what allah wants
right and that will give you the
greatest
ecstasy that nothing can give you
yeah you're enjoying it
you're enjoying this that's that's
beautiful man
[Music]
man this was such a i was so present
during this you know
yeah it was just a flow state you look
like you live in the gym so i'm sure
that analogy worked with you miranda
or me i'm fine yeah
bro yes that's the last time i've been
to a gym well i was looking at your
biceps in that
whatsapp um what do you have it that
picture you had i was like a lot of work
but
what is that you don't want my dp
no like my my profile picture yeah yeah
yeah yeah bro i've been to guess the
last time i've been to a gym
when i want to say december or january
what yeah bro we've been in lockdown
since
well you went gym before right yeah yeah
yeah so you're maintaining the
the muscle and those bro i don't even
i'm barely working out now
i'll work out like 10 minutes a day now
how old are you
i'm 23. yeah your metabolism is quite
high your testosterone's high so you're
going to maintain it
when you're my age when i'm like 36 now
then you have to go gym regularly
because if you if you drop
a few weeks you put on the pounds your
testosterone
level is lower your uh metabolism is
slower as well
so at your age yeah yeah of course
you're going to maintain that physique
oh sure that's true and one last thing i
want to throw in here
to like tie in what you were saying yeah
you know how you said if someone's a
critical thinker
they'll think about this and and they'll
eventually get to these
existential questions where it will lead
them to the truth right
well let's say someone's not even that
much of a critical thinker
if someone's just ambitious enough
right let's say you're ambitious and you
say you know what
i want to be a professional um
football player i want to be a
professional fighter
i want to be an entrepreneur and i want
to have all these businesses i want to
be a billionaire i want to do all these
things
right like at some point or another you
start to
actually achieve these things and when
you achieve these things you realize
like
oh is is this it is this it
like brother there's times where in the
past like when i was
really skinny i remember when i first
started working out it was um
it was eleventh grade or maybe it was
ten dollars
a lot knows the best a lot of weather
but i started working out and i wanted
to get bigger
and then when i got bigger i looked in
the mirror i was like
nah nah nah i need to get even bigger
then i'll be good
and then when i got even bigger i was
like i need to get even bigger and i got
to the point
where i was weighing close to 200 pounds
i had joint
issues because of how heavy i was i was
no longer athletic i couldn't move
the way that i used to and i looked at
myself i'm like
all this time you've been trying to get
bigger and like look what it's giving
you
it has not given you any any hint of
happiness any hint of satisfaction any
hint of achievement
and then i thought to myself ah you know
what it's because i'm carrying too much
weight it's because i need to be defined
i need to be ripped
so then now i went from this mountain
let me climb this mountain over here
but then when i got to that mountain to
the peak i was like oh damn
like this this isn't it either what is
it what is it
and again like if someone's ambitious
they'll get to the point where
they're gonna ask the question is this
really it
like am am i really just living life to
just
climb this mountain get to the peak and
then go to the next mountain
well i'm constantly searching for
happiness constantly searching for
that uh that fulfillment bro
listen bro i'm gonna say something right
now which might piss a lot of people off
i'm very against the whole extreme end
of powerlifting
you see these dudes going to the gym
lifting an
unhealthy dangerous abnormal amount of
weight
where they could literally herniate
their disc or just like
they're doing all they're snorting all
these things i forgot what they're
called these chemicals
huh ammonia ammonia yeah
um it's just different nitrogen
compounds right so they're doing that
yeah they're doing that they're uh
they're you know
bleeding and they sometimes they do get
injured right
um i've seen people tear their pecs like
bro what are you doing this for
like i'm all for you know run run faster
climb harder go to the next level of
course bro
of course but there's this extreme end
of powerlifting that you see
they're just obsessed with hitting that
new pr new pr new pr
and it's just like come on bro like is
like do you really think that's that's
going to give you the satisfaction that
you're looking for
because once you hit that you're like
okay i did 205 let me go for 225 then
315.
then 405 is where does it end
you know what's interesting about that
is if we look at the narration of the
process alone where
the prophet sallam said if the son of
adam is given one valley of gold
then he would want another right so
a valley of gold is more than enough for
the rest of your life
but the son of adam wants another and
then nothing will satisfy
him except the sand in the belly as in
when you die and you decay and then sand
is you know
going through your bones and stuff
something like this i'm just
paraphrasing the narration
of what i'm here the thing is
honestly some of these guys seen the gym
are freaks
some why by freaks is
i just today just before this podcast
for some reason i was on google looking
at vince mcmahon back in the days when
he became hench
he's 75 and when he was in his 50s he
started doing steroids and started doing
looking huge right you know the
chairman of wwf wwe and
freakish freakish it doesn't even look
nice
but what it is is you have to do
something greater and greater and
greater and greater
because you're trying to get to that
place but the problem is that place
doesn't exist
it only exists in your mind but allah
allah is there to tell you allah doesn't
care
about these things you know you're poor
you're rich allah will answer your dua
you are somebody who's a sinner
or you're a saint allah will still
answer your prayer
you are somebody who is trying to you
know
change their life or you're somebody
that's really struggling in pain or
whoever you are a lot
is there for you so you know
people sometimes have these very
negative stories about themselves
i'm too old or i'm too fat or i'm ugly
or i'm this one that
the fact is you should be happy as long
as you are having a good relationship
with allah that's it
just have a good relationship with allah
and you're successful
you know it's quite sad but you know we
do have to talk about this
how many people do we find who i you
know
what looks like at the peak of their
life and later on they didn't know but
they actually had cancer
you know um there's uh
a guy who muhammad hijab and ali dawa
they were debating in speaker's corner
and so did hamza
sees this sikh guy right so
he was it the the basics of sikhi or
something yeah based basics is the key
right
so this guy um
he was somebody who
was making videos about sikhism he
looked like he was living quite a
healthy lifestyle
i remember i met him in speaker's corner
i took his number as well because i
wanted to set up another discussion
between him and hamza and you know i i
remember that day
um you know people come to the park and
you know you get thirsty some person
can have a fizzy drink with them or
coffee i remember he had coconut water i
was like oh this guy must be quite
healthy because he's having this
and um you know practicing sikhs they're
like they're quite
like they leave vegetarian stuff um they
won't drink
you know so he looked very healthy um
he studied at oxford university he's an
intelligent guy
right and you know subhanallah
the guy while he was talking to us i we
didn't know he didn't know but he had
cancer
and i remember i was talking to him on
whatsapp um
and i was trying to set up something and
then i remember he didn't reply for some
time and i was like
oh he stopped replying oh what's going
on then i found out that he had cancer
and then you know i was discussing with
hamza we need to go see
and we need to go um you know just just
meet him and stuff and
out of nowhere then it was very
aggressive cancer and he died
literally a few months after that
discussion that's that's still online
you know and how many stories do we know
this i have i have somebody that
i knew at school and this guy was a
super intelligent guy
he went off to oxford university to
study philosophy he came out he was an
athlete
he was doing rock climbing he fell and
he died
other people you know they at the peak
of their life to die in you know
motorcycle
accidents sometimes people just die
suddenly
like sudden death is happening now right
um i just read the other day about this
guy
who passed away and he was like the
doctors didn't know why he passed away
just just some sudden death and the
police said there's nothing
suspicious uh that they know he just
died
the thing is this life is scary
we don't really like to think of it this
way but it is scary you don't know how
long you have
like today is friday there's seven days
of the week
one of these days is the day that you're
going to pass away it's going to be one
of these seven
right it's kind of scary when you think
about it
and then eternity all your doors
are closed except for the good that
you've left here
and you know this is why i try and do
this and i don't do this enough but i
recommend this to
everybody watching constantly remind
yourself of death
death is going to bring out the best of
you uh robert greene
he's this author who writes you know
about
i'm sure you've heard of him laws of
human nature and
33 strategies of war you know he he gave
this talk and it was so interesting he
said
when you think about death then every
moment you suck out the best of it
and you you give life like more meaning
and everything comes together
now obviously him he's not giving the
spiritual element he's just talking
about
value but it's true when you
think about death you forget all the
trivial things and you just focus on the
most important thing
and for us as muslims the most important
thing is allah
romans have a saying called memento mori
which basically means remember your
death
and you're not the the first person
that's
you know mentioned this because bro it's
been a short time span here but we had
this brother on that we were
interviewing uh
zach he was an ex-cartel leader i said
yeah man marshall bro he's he was saying
the same thing about that
he it's like people remind themselves of
death like he lives a life
where he could literally die at any
second like the cartel can come into his
house
while he's sleeping and that's it game
over he's still in mexico bro he doesn't
want to get the hell out
yeah he's there because he has a purpose
well i protect him i mean
in a way it's sometimes
a blessing when somebody knows they have
cancer
or somebody knows that they're in that
danger you can get a false sense of
security
you know and robert greene also says
this that when you're in your 30s or
your 40s you think oh so your 20s or
your 30s you think you have these
worst eons of time ahead of you
it's not true it's not true at all you
could pass away tomorrow
even if you live up to a ripe age of 80.
you go up to an 80 year old and you say
to him do you remember when you were 15
they'd say yeah i remember you're 15.
how long ago it felt like yesterday
like i remember being you know i was
just talking to my missus about
today how fast time goes right like 20
years ago
i remember what happened i remember
watching tv i remember
going to school i remember these things
and
20 years later it feels like yesterday i
was 15.
and you know i'm sure that's why people
in the 80 they they feel
you know like life went past very fast
you know in the quran allah teaches us
that
you know when people are resurrected in
the day of judgment they're going to
think they lived on this earth
for like a moment for like a short
afternoon
short morning because that's what life
really is
that's facts it's real bro that's real
if i were to ask y'all right now oh
just go ahead recap the last 10 years of
your life
what you you'll be able to tell me like
a few little things
and that's because everything else in
between that was mundane
everything just kind of blended in
together and that's what happens when
you aren't really like i guess you don't
have that uh
awareness that you are gonna die
you know you start living as if you're
gonna live forever but that's not the
truth
so man i don't know i speak for myself
bro
you know what's interesting about that
is that
you will regret everything that you've
done
right but you will not regret
remembering allah
even this conversation right
we're remembering allah we're talking
about allah
you know you will not regret when you
like you said you were praying and then
you looked out at the beach and you
you had that remembrance of allah at
that point
even sometimes i like watching nature
documentaries
right planet earth and blue planet and
you know all these types of things
because for me that's remembering a lot
you know you're sitting there watching
all of these amazing plants and animals
and their strategies and
how they mimic each other in their
different colors and you're like
you know we we sometimes forget
to do the most simple things and you
know i was reading as i was listening to
a book recently
about how our lives are full of clutter
you know in a 10 minute
window we're thinking about what's for
dinner
where am i going to take my children to
school
um you know where's that five pound note
i left somewhere
oh this guy he said something to me the
other day what did he say oh that's
really annoying what did he mean by that
in a 10-minute window you're probably
going to think of 50
completely different topics which are
trivial
absolutely trivial and your mind is
continuously flowing between these
random thoughts
social media has made it worse because
now you actually scroll through
the stats are that 27.5 meters
of scrolling we do every single day like
one mutual is there like 27.5
meters and all of that is garbage right
what you have to do is you have to and
we human beings forget but you have to
stop think about allah stop think about
allah
even in your scrolling or this or that
that's why i like sometimes that
brothers and sisters put up islamic
reminders
so when you're in this scrolling habit
of oh you're just watching a cat
going down you know this
jumping on this ball or something else
and you're scrolling you just watching
these random videos sometimes happens
before you're sleeping you're just
trying to tie yourself out then someone
puts an islamic reminder
and it breaks your flow right of
scrolling
that person has basically helped you get
closer to allah so i really like it when
you know people post stuff like that but
usually
we waste so much time on social media
through scrolling
or scrolling in our minds with
completely
disconnected and trivial issues which is
why
you know the reminder benefits the
believer we have to continuously remind
ourselves we're here for something far
greater than these trivialities
this is one of the realest episodes
we've had
mashallah i say that every week bro but
it's because it's a good sign because
because we're getting better bro
for making the time to be here any
closing words any
closing pieces of advice for anyone
listening
i am i've been thinking about something
nowadays um i really feel sorry
for your generation young people now
i'm not like very much older than you
i'm like what
14 years older than you guys but what i
mean by that is that the fitna
that existed when i was your age right
when i was
in my early 20s or late teens or
whatever
it wasn't that bad right
you know nowadays you get these apps and
i only
know of these things superfluously
through articles or you know you get
these videos on
what's this sidemen or something that
keeps coming up on my algorithm right
side
side men reacts or whatever they have
this thing like tinder swipes where
it's like um stuff i shouldn't be
promoting these apps i'm not
just saying it's a well-known thing
right you get this thing where
they do a real life thing where i don't
watch the videos but it comes up on your
um algorithm and this is obviously a
well-known thing people swipe
they choose partners they do this they
do that the ability to do zina
the ability to do drugs the access
to you know materialism the pull towards
materialism this the jarlich world view
is so strong you know i i often think
that you know young people
they're like protecting themselves
they're not talking to the other gender
they're not
you know going into these materialistic
things yet they see people all around
them
looking like they're enjoying themselves
you know you you'll find this continuous
thing like
uh you know what if they're enjoying
themselves and i'm young and i'm not
enjoying my souls
like the fitnah is so strong
and i literally think to myself it is a
miracle of islam it is a miracle of iman
is a miracle of
allah that they are young people who are
like
banda i'm not accepting this nonsense
i'm gonna worship allah i am not going
to give up
this uh relationship that i have with
allah
for these trivialities and i've seen
more young people are practicing now
than they were when i was younger like
there's
so many holocausts so many talks so many
if you go to universities
way more hijabis than before way more
practicing brothers than before
way more knowledge circles than before
way more people involved in bower than
before
yet the fitnah is greater and you think
yourself
how is this possible so i honestly
you know i i i'm
i'm astonished the fact at the fact that
there are people who are strangers
like this who exist and i would say stay
strong
stay strong because you know the true
happiness
is on this side the grass looks green on
the other side
but it's artificial and it's poisoned
the real grass is on this side
right and i don't think i can give a
stronger message to the youth
than to remember the story of yusuf
al-islam and how
being strong upon your faith allah will
establish you on this earth
i mean oh me i mean man what a wonderful
note turn it off
i know you got any thoughts yeah the
last thing that i want to say brother
he's on regards to what you said earlier
about your dad and man
may allah accept him in the genre
hundred percent a lot of vietnam and all
of us in the highest ranks i mean right
guys if you made it this far
smash that like button link in the
description to find brother sabor's
youtube channel
and his work salaam alaikum
warahmatullahi
so my eyes character is a thing about a
video game think about a movie you think
about a book
you have different characters the
character
is uh the expressions the actions
the personality the traits of this
individual
good character would imply obviously
that this person leads
towards good bad would imply that they
lean towards bad but
having character in general uh implies
authenticity or at least
i would say good character implies
[Music]
authenticity
[Music]
[Music]
um